I'm going to speak today about the role
of the Andrew W Mellon foundations
long-standing grant-making commitment in
the domain of art conservation with a
particular focus on our historical
strategy for building a sustainable
pipeline of highly skilled conservators
within the United States I'll then speak
briefly about the role of conservation
in interdisciplinary curriculum efforts
on campuses and finally conclude with a
snapshot of some of our current
international conservation training
initiatives most of which you've already
heard about which will save a lot of
time oh my slides do not look correct oh
alright well at least you can see the
big number that's the important thing to
contextualize the scale of the
foundation's investment in our
conservation I'll start with this
impressive figure to highlight the long
duration of the foundation's commitment
to this field profession and practice as
the largest and most consistent funder
of conservation in the United States
most trained conservators whether
employed and cultural heritage
institutions or in private practice have
benefited from these investments at some
point in their career most of them many
times over in the form of subsidy for
their graduate education fellowships
paid positions or training workshops
there are some very specific
programmatic directions encompassed in
that large number you just saw the top
is of this slide illustrates the breadth
of melons approach to the full scope of
building a professional infrastructure
and training pipeline and the bottom
shows areas of depth where funds have
gone to long-term capacity building
initiatives there's of course some
overlap in these approaches for example
in the category of photograph
conservation during the decade of the
2000s the foundation undertook a
ten-year 45 million dollar initiative to
construct and sustain a mature
professional pipeline of highly skilled
photo conservators just at the moment
when chemical photography gave way to
digital before entire systems of
knowledge would be lost funding in this
area was inclusive of all of the top
categories as you've heard the u.s.
currently has four graduate art
conservation programs that produce the
majority of practitioners in the
melon is one of many funders that
support the programs though probably the
largest and most consistent over time
historically the foundation has taken an
approach of relative equity toward these
programs and distribution of resources
to ensure a stable ecosystem that is in
balance with market supply and demand
and to produce a reasonable level of
consistency and skillset and proficiency
among graduates and Debbie spoke to this
very eloquently earlier the cost of an
advanced degree in conservation is high
three to four years of graduate study
are required to build the solid
foundation of knowledge and skills and
full time schedules of lectures seminars
research and laboratory work prevents
students from supplementing their
resources through outside employment
most students except unpaid thank you to
Yale for having paid pre-program
professional internships before they
even enroll in a graduate program and
must pay course fees for chemistry art
history and studio art to supplement
their preparation to acquire necessary
for requisites for admission moreover
once enrolled students frequently take
unpaid or low paid summer internships in
order to gain essential training
graduates enter an extremely competitive
and oftentimes a low-paying job market
where candidates commonly spend a number
of years in fellowships and placements
before securing an entry-level position
in a museum library or in private
practice the funding highlighted here
has gone largely to support student
stipends curriculum development faculty
positions and some specialized
programming Mellon grants do not support
tuition this must either be paid by the
student or the schools are must find
other forms of subsidy these figures
reflect dollars give an outright they
don't reflect any sums of matching money
raised against our grants it's a
mechanism we frequently use to
incentivize a leveraging effect for our
funds if we were to calculate that these
numbers would be much much higher the
point here is to emphasize that the
foundation has initiated and sustained
funding over time we do not simply
respond to ad hoc requests or
specialized interests we've operated
with an intentional and incremental
incremental capacity
building strategy that has allowed these
universities to overtime better sustain
the necessary training infrastructure
working in close connection with Museum
Library and heritage communities and as
Debbie so eloquently said these are
collaborative competitors the programs
work very closely together and I think
we intend through our funding to help
reinforce that idea that the programs
together serve as a cohort even though
they do during admissions season get
very competitive despite the
long-standing focus and dollars spent it
would be misleading to say that
conservation training and practice
exists in isolation the foundation has
maintained a deep interest in fostering
interdisciplinary practices in the
humanities including promoting the use
of objects as the basis for scholarly
research the more fluent our future art
historians and curators are in working
directly with objects the more
productive and equitable the dialogue
with conservation colleagues becomes and
the more new knowledge is produced this
slide shows a selection of universities
where this kind of interdisciplinary
curriculum is being enacted increasingly
drawing on conservators and there are
scientists counterparts from campuses or
in partnering museums as teachers
because they hold so much specialized
knowledge concerning materials
techniques identification of process and
methods of examination and analysis the
campuses that house conservation
programs are highlighted here in red to
show it's no coincidence there might be
an increased capacity and appetite for
object study in these environments it's
the Foundation's continued expectation
that by drawing future curators and
scholars into closer connection with
conservation counterparts in earlier
stages of their professional formation
they will begin to craft more
sophisticated questions feel more
comfortable seeking out conservation and
scientific expertise and produced more
robust and collaborative forms of
scholarship further i'll just say on a
personal note it's my personal wish that
conservators continue to achieve more
equitable status with their historically
privileged carrot oriole counterparts
within cultural institutions precisely
because of the
of their specialized knowledge as I
conclude this is the promised snapshot
of our internationally based programs
the foundation has recently supported
most of which you've already heard
mentioned in earlier talks from my
distinguished colleagues who can all
speak to them in much greater depth than
I could so please raise questions during
the discussion period if you're
interested the foundation takes a
limited stance in international
grant-making but we occasionally seize
on opportunities where collaboration and
some targeted grant programs can have an
outsized impact on particular identified
needs I thank you all for your attention
and look forward to the discussion